DR. JAMES GRIME: We're going
to talk about vampires.
Yes, math and vampires.
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: Well, my
youngest daughter, today is
having two teeth out.
So she probably won't like
this one very much.
A vampire number is where--
DR. JAMES GRIME: You have
two numbers that
are the same length--
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: --a
number with an even number of
digits, split into the product
of two numbers--
DR. JAMES GRIME: And
the result has
to use all the digits--
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: 4 digits
of the original number,
you must use the same digits.
2 numbers, each with 2 digits,
of the 4 digits of the 2
numbers multiplying
them together.
Yeah, not great.
I wasn't ready.
Maybe, I'll write it down.
BRADY HARAN: Gonna
write it down?
Yeah, let's write
it next to it.
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: 1260,
that's a 4 digit number.
OK?
And I can write it as
a product of 2 digit
numbers, 21 times 60.
And you can see that the same
4 digits that make up the
original number appear
in the new numbers.
These are my 2 fangs.
And this is my original
vampire.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Let's
try another one.
125,460, this is a
vampire number.
Let's have a look
at its fangs.
That's 204 times 615.
But I like this one because
there's 2 ways to do it.
So we could have done
246 times 510.
So let's have a look
at the numbers.
So what have we got?
We've got 2, 0, 4, 6, 1, 5.
Do that again.
2, this time 4, 6, 5, 1, 0.
Same six numbers also but used
in a different order.
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: There are
also three fang numbers.
Shall we do that?
1, 3, 0, 7, 8, 2, 6, 0.
OK?
That can be split in
the following ways.
1, 6, 2, 0, times 8, 0, 7, 3.
Here's another way.
1,863 times 7,020.
2,070 times 6, 3, 1, 8.
There are numbers with 4 pairs
of fangs known, five pairs of
fangs known.
I bet you can keep going.
DR. JAMES GRIME: This
is the one I like.
All right.
This one, now I think kids,
is really cool.
I won't tell you its name yet.
But it's this, so it's 117,067
and the fangs are
1, 6, 7, times 701.
And these fangs are
prime numbers.
So this is a prime vampire
number, and the fangs are its
prime factorization, which is
this hugely important thing in
math, when you can break
it into primes.
So when you break into primes,
you get the fangs.
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: When
you're writing down these
numbers, you're not allowed to
have pairs of numbers which
are trailing zeroes
at the end.
You see, if we just look back
here, you'll see these numbers
there's one 0 at the end of one
number, but not at the end
of the other.
In each case here there's one
0 here, but not here.
So you're not allowed to have
combinations where this is a 0
at the end of each number.
They don't count.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Why not?
PROFESSOR ED COPELAND: It's to
do with the way that you can
create a whole series of extra
numbers that don't fit into
this category.
DR. JAMES GRIME: In traditional
folklore, one of
the weaknesses of vampires is
that they suffered from
something called arithmomania,
and this is the
compulsion to count.
It might of made a good name
for "Numberphile." We could
have done that.
It's a type of a OCD though.
It's a real condition, but in
traditional folklore, this is
what the vampires were
said to suffer from.
I think it came from other
tales, like when you're sent
to hell, and you're damned,
and you're forced to count
grains of sand on an
infinite beach.
It's a torture.
It's one way to avoid
the vampire.
So when they're chasing you,
if you throw sand on the
floor, some grains of wheat,
they'll be compelled to stop,
and count the grains of sand.
The most famous sufferer,
though, of arithmomania would
have to be to the Count
from "Sesame Street".
Yes?
Because he counts the
candle on the shelf.
And when he's alone
he counts himself.
BRADY HARAN: You've got
another favorite?
DR. JAMES GRIME: I've got
my most favorite.
Now this, I love.
Alright, I'll do here.
Because you can do with Roman
numerals, as well.
This is my favorite.
2 in Roman numerals times
4, is equal to 8.
So do we have 3 eyes and
a V on each one?
Yes, we do.
We've got the V there,
and I, I, I. Perfect.
So you can do it with Roman
numerals, as well.
BRADY HARAN: That's
pretty cool.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Ah huh,
it's fun isn't it?
BRADY HARAN: What's
that called?
DR. JAMES GRIME: What
shall we call it?
Let's name it.
We'll call it a Caesar
vampire number.
Done.
Sam and Neil have devised,
what to me, is a new
experiment for Halloween.